welcome to our
next session um we have casper and megan
who will give us wonderful talks about
um ai and explainability and automation
um
we are starting a little bit late we're
about like 10 minutes or so behind
schedule so we will probably eat
a little bit into our lunch time but we
have plenty of lunch time left anyway so
we should be fine um but without further
ado i'll hand it to kesper and i will
um and we will keep all the questions
again um to the end of both talks all
right thank you so much uh i'm kasper
i'm a research fellow in machine
learning at the rmit university in
melbourne australia
and
i mostly work on explainability from a
technical perspective so computer
science machine learning ai
and recently i've been rethinking
the whole concept of explainability i
kind of found there's
a lot of foundation lacking and yet we
are developing these new methods
so
this talk is basically me
trying to go back to the very basics and
try to discover what's there
and what are the problems but before we
do that let's just have a brief brief
look at automated decision making
so this is more or less my understanding
of what's happening there so we have a
natural phenomenon
that we observe and it generates some
data
we use this data then to train our
models that generate predictions and
then we can plug in an explainer and
this explainer produces explanations
there is a human at the end
obviously the human the explainee can
interact with any of these elements but
then also
this person comes with a background
knowledge
so the observations of the world or
whatever and
this basically comprises of a technical
aspect of this system which are the red
blocks blocks more or less and then the
natural aspect which are the blue boxes
and what i'm interested in is how it all
interacts
and how can we make it more appealing
and let's say more reasonable
so
at the very beginning of explainability
let's let's call it the beginning uh it
was mostly a technical skill
we're generating this insight and we're
happy about it it was mostly computer
scientists playing around but then tim
came along and he said look
there
you're missing something there is this
human
who who should receive these
explanations and
you you're basically generating it for
the human and not just in a vacuum
and then the field kind of shifted
completely
more towards humans so how do humans
perceive explanations what sort of
explanations humans like
they should be interactive probably
conversational
probably counterfactuals so we really
like hypothetical situations what if
well if this was not as it is how would
it end up
but then i think that
we got so
in love with this concept
that we actually started
overcompensating and focusing too much
on humans and treating these systems
only from a human perspective whereas
if you think about it carefully
explainers
are technical objects so they may
generate these insights that are
directed towards humans but they also
have a lot of technical things going
underneath the hood
so
let me give you two examples one is from
a technical perspective and the other
one is from more from a social
perspective we'll start with the
technical bit
so
let's assume that we have an image
and some predictive model and this is
what we get out of that model so it's
mostly 99
tennis ball prediction and then some
probability for
a golden retriever and labrador
retriever
and we're asking why
why is this particular
prediction
reasonable
so this is an example of an explanation
and let me walk you through that so
what's happening here is we take this
image
we split it into non-overlapping chunks
and
we probe the model by saying well
if we remove one of these chunks or a
random combination of these chunks how
does the model respond
so we're basically trying to see
which parts of this image are sensitive
for a particular prediction
and then once we run the my stats so we
we
remove random patterns based on this
division of the image and we quantify
how much does removing certain patterns
certain parts of this image influence
the prediction and this is our
explanation so the two pictures on the
left
are explanations
visualized in a different way so
that they are complementary actually so
it tells you well segment number one
and number five which are the two in the
background
contribute negatively towards the
prediction of a tennis ball and then the
ones colored in green contribute in a
positive way towards that prediction
so having these segments there
gives you a tangible predictions whereas
if you remove them you may not get
a tennis ball fraction and then the
the bar chart quantifies how much
this actually these segments actually
influence the prediction
and then we can do and you know this is
kind of reasonable there is some
background noise there because you get
these important bits of the background
the image which you may question further
but in essence it picks up on the tennis
ball which is great
but what if you explain golden retriever
well then you get
some positive influence from the
background and what this explanation
basically tells you well if the tennis
ball is not there then it's a golden
retriever which isn't
a very good explanation
so
you may want to probe that further
and
this is what i've got here so basically
there are two
parameters for this explainer it's a
very basic explainer
and what you can change is one how you
remove information from that image
because you obviously can't just
remove them you need a proxy for that
and the proxy in this case is occlusion
so you remove information from the image
by replacing that particular partition
of the image with a fixed color so in
this case we have a bunch of colors to
test
and i'll go through them in a moment and
then the second parameter is
how many segments you generate so how do
you split
the image so you can increase
the number of segments and on the right
here you can see the randomization
pattern that you get so these are all of
these images that then
we use to probe the
black box
and then the explanation that we get on
the left
so
if you look carefully at that if we
change the occlusion color
the explanation changes quite
drastically
and this is also
relevant for other colors
so you can see that this parameter
actually
affects quite significantly how we
generate the explanation what we get out
of it
and then
the same applies to
how many segments we generate for that
image
so if we increase the number of segments
you can again see that the explanation
changes
and
as you increase the number of segments
it changes even further an interesting
observation here
is that actually some
some parameter choices are more
reasonable than others
and if we look at
this occlusion
which basically replaces
each part of the image with the average
color
in that segment
as we increase
the number of segments
you can see that the removal strategy
isn't quite that effective what we're
basically doing we're blurring the image
we're decreasing its quality but we're
not really hiding the information
and this is the core premise of this
explainer we want to remove this
information in order to quantify
how much it influences the prediction so
if we go ahead with this method and use
the average occlusion and then split the
image into multiple segments we're
basically not doing anything we're just
so so then the explanation won't be
meaningful possibly
so that's one aspect
of explainability the technical aspect
and then there's the other one which is
how do you present this information so
you've seen with the previous one there
were two complementary figures one was
the importance overlaid on top of the
image
and the other one was a bar plot that
showed the
magnitude
of these importance factors
but there are multiple ways so
let's say that we have distilled our
explanation into this linear equation
and this may not be very informative for
you and you may just doze off now saying
okay that's
i don't want to have to deal with that
but it actually
so we there are a few ways in which you
can interpret this so one is you forget
about your data points so this your data
point this is the
the explanation the model that is
reasonably simple
so you may just focus on the top part
and i say okay the feature number one
is important 0.25 this is the importance
then feature number four is 0.7 but then
if you want to apply it to a specific
instance specific data point you
actually need to do some math
and then you plug this vector in
you do calculations and this is what you
get as a result so then you can kind of
quantify
the importance of each
feature for this particular instance
but that again requires quite a lot of
reasoning and you need to know what
you're doing so we probably can simplify
that
and that's basically
more or less the same information we
lose quite a lot because we don't get
the equation we can't experiment with it
anymore but this is
representing the same information
for the particular instance that i
showed you on the previous slide so
that's a bit more reasonable you see
that the base prediction is
0.2 and then feature number one pushes
it a bit to the right
and then five and seven to the left and
number four
more to do all right and you end up with
prediction 0.6 so more or less it
captures the same information and
probably that's more accessible
but we can go in further so here again
we required some reasoning
and that's again the same information
shown in a completely different way
and i would argue that this is
yet even more accessible so you see that
there is this base value of 0.2 you end
up with a prediction of 0.6 and then
there are these features that push to
the left and to the right
and you know you end up here
so
there's less reasoning required on the
human part to actually get what's
happening
so
having seen that there are these two
aspects the social one
and the technical one can we actually
use this to map out
how explainability works
and this are a few of my ideas so first
of all just asking
does the explanation work is meaningless
how do you define work is it your user
study if the users were happy with it
then it works but there is so much
context that you can't capture
that i think it's meaningless to ask
these sort of questions so
can we zoom in
and i think that by distinguishing
between the technical aspects
and the presentation aspects the social
aspect we can actually do a bit better
so
then we have
two ideas to navigate one
is the explanatory insight correct and
by explanatory insight i mean the
numerical representation that you
extract as your explanation
is it correct or is it not
and then the other aspect is how do you
present them is it convincing is it
accessible or not and then you may end
up with all sorts of different troubles
so for example
if your insight is correct
but the the presentation medium isn't
very good you're not really explaining
because
you won't communicate effectively
if you are presenting it in a convincing
and effective way and it is correct then
great that's basically explainability
but then you can go all the way to the
left side so
if it's incorrect but convincing
then you're basically persuading people
you're saying look this is what it is
and it's potentially harmful if people
believe in that
then
well if you want to manipulate people
that's great but if you want to explain
it's not so good
and then if it's incorrect and
ineffective well you're not doing much
but that's just capturing one aspect of
it so here we're dealing with the model
and with the inside but if we go back
to the actual phenomenon that generates
the data then we are in a completely
different
we're asking a completely different
question because now we're saying well
if the model is correct with respect to
the phenomenon
and we're generating some insights these
are
explanations because they correspond to
how the world works
whereas if the model is incorrect if it
predicts wrong
and you're generating some insights then
what you're doing is basically debugging
the model you're trying to figure out
why the model
gave you the wrong answer so that's not
so much explainability
as debugging so it would serve a
different role basically
and
having said that
what what can we learn from this sort of
differentiation
well first of all
you probably need more than one insight
and possibly spanning more than one
category of explanations so you want to
see
many insights and then reason about them
to
build a coherent picture
of what's happening inside your
predictive model
then also explainability is not really a
binary thing because what is explainable
to you may not be explainable to me what
i may find
transparent for other people maybe
you'll pay so for example if you go back
to the example of different presentation
modes then i can handle the equation
just fine whereas other people may
prefer
one of the plots and
you know there are different
different ways in which we understand
so basically
this would lead us to a conclusion that
explainability tools
are just diagnostic tools there is not
much explanation happening unless we
actually understand
what are the assumptions under which we
operate
and how to interpret their results
because you may see a bar plot
and i may see a bar plot and we may have
a completely different perception of
what it conveys
just because i may have some background
if you don't
and this actually leads me to finally
define explainability
so i define explainability as
understanding it has to lead to
something
and whatever understanding is in this
case i don't know it was probably
context dependent but what you want in
the end is understanding
and understanding is achieved by
gathering some transparent insight and
again transpiring this subjective
you want something that is transparent
to you
and you reason about it given your
background
knowledge whether it's technical
knowledge
or
domain knowledge and you could see that
for example
with the the very first example that i
gave with a linear equation you actually
had to do some reasoning in order to
extract the explanation possibly
generate some meanings and understanding
and this very much depends on what you
present
in what context and to whom
thanks so much
[Applause]
foreign